"Echo" isn't just a cool name for a superhero;
it also reflects how the character and the
series embrace the past to forge a new future.
Here's how the ending of "Echo" brings it
all together.
"Echo" takes place directly after the events
of "Hawkeye."
In that show, Maya Lopez learns from Clint
Barton that Kingpin anonymously hired him,
as Ronin, to assassinate her father and several
other members of the Tracksuit Mafia.
Maya then leaves Kingpin's organization and
confronts her former friend Kazi Kazimierczak,
killing him during the Tracksuit Mafia's battle
against Clint and Kate Bishop.
Maya later ambushes Fisk and shoots him, seemingly
putting an end to New York City's greatest
gangster.
When "Echo" picks up, Maya returns to her
hometown of Tamaha, Oklahoma to take over
Fisk's operations there.
She locks horns with her Uncle Henry, who,
like Maya's father, was involved with Kingpin's
organization against his will.
After attracting unwanted attention from the
Kingpin's henchmen, Maya discovers that Fisk
is alive, and he offers her a chance to return
to New York and resume operations as his "Queenpin."
"You want an empire, you'll have it."
All the while, Maya is also having recurring
visions of her ancestors, including the first
Choctaw woman, Chafa, as well as Tuklo, a
Choctaw warrior from the 1800s.
She's also confronting her strained relationships
with her family members, including her cousin
Bonnie, whom she avoided contact with following
her father's death, and her grandmother Chula,
whose anger towards Maya's father left them
estranged.
Maya learns the truth about her visions from
Chula, realizing that her ancestors are contacting
her during critical moments.
She later confronts Kingpin in his hotel room
and nearly accepts his offer to kill him,
calling back to his own experience of killing
his father to free himself from an abusive
household.
Maya refuses.
Most of the finale centers on Tamaha's Choctaw
Nation Powwow, a festival celebrating their
ancestry.
The Tracksuit Mafia arrive in search of Maya,
forcing Henry and Maya's cousin Biscuits to
hold them off.
Wearing a costume given to her by Chula, Maya
gets cornered by Kingpin and his henchmen,
who have taken Chula and Bonnie hostage.
Kingpin threatens to kill them so that he's
the only family Maya has left, but Maya uses
her ancestral powers for the first time to
not only fight off Fisk's goons, but to empower
Chula and Bonnie to fight alongside her.
Finally, Maya takes control of Fisk's mind,
sending him back to pivotal moments in his
life, including the moment before he decided
to kill his father.
She encourages him to let go of his pain.
Fisk, terrified of Maya's powers and perhaps
his own memories, abandons his plan and escapes
with his remaining henchmen.
Before Maya leaves Tamaha, she visits her
family at a barbecue and is warmly welcomed,
all of them now free from Kingpin's control.
"Echo" involves Maya completing her transformation
from villain to superhero.
Characters such as Wanda Maximoff and Loki
have made the transition from villain to hero,
and occasionally back, putting Maya in good
company among the Marvel Cinematic Universe's
roster of evildoers turned good guys.
"Again.
Faster."
When Maya is introduced in "Hawkeye," she's
relentlessly chasing down Ronin for killing
her father, targeting Kate Bishop and later
Clint Barton.
Audiences can still empathize with Maya during
this villain arc, though, especially after
flashback sequences show her father encouraging
her to adapt to a world that won't accept
her.
When Fisk turns up alive in "Echo," Maya must
choose between her family and her ambition.
It raises the question: Why does Maya choose
to be a hero rather than the "Queenpin"?
The answers lie in the flashback sequences
depicting Maya's history working for Kingpin,
where she misinterprets his affection for
her as paternal.
It's actually strategic.
Fisk is no stranger to using cruel, manipulative
tactics against those close to him.
Case in point, in episode 4 of "Echo," he
brings Maya her favorite cookies to entice
her into listening to him.
The only difference is, this time around,
Maya is too wise to trust Fisk.
After all, she didn't pour out an expensive
bottle of wine for no reason.
"It came highly recommended."
"Hawkeye" only briefly examines Maya's history
with Wilson Fisk, revealing that her father,
William, was Fisk's partner in operating the
Tracksuit Mafia.
Fisk took on the role of an uncle figure in
Maya's life.
This is fleshed out much further through flashback
sequences in "Echo."
In one important flashback in episode 4, Fisk
is surprised when a young Maya joins him in
assaulting a rude ice cream vendor.
This is the start of Maya's transformation
into one of Fisk's closest commanders.
This establishes that Kingpin saw something
in Maya early on that made her a valuable
asset to his criminal empire.
He never had to lure her into his world of
corruption.
She was a willing participant.
Even the act of Fisk assaulting the vendor
proves that his love for Maya is genuine,
though still as toxic as any of Fisk's other
relationships.
No more is this apparent as in Fisk's relationship
to American Sign Language, or ASL, the only
way for him and Maya to communicate.
While every other character in "Echo" is fluent
in ASL, Fisk is not, which Maya calls him
out on as evidence that he doesn't truly care
about her.
Comic Basics interpreted this as an example
of Fisk's shortcomings as a character, writing,
"Kingpin was likely incapable of truly bonding
with people, and since Maya saw him as some
kind of heroic personality when she was little,
Kingpin liked it."
Family is a major theme in "Echo," with one
of the very first scenes depicting the traumatic
car crash that tore Maya's family apart.
When Maya returns to Tamaha, tensions run
high between her and her relatives.
There's her Uncle Henry, who is still involved
in Fisk's organization; her grandmother, Chula,
who turned her back on Maya and her father
years ago; and Bonnie, Maya's closest childhood
friend who she's desperate to keep away from
the criminal world.
Along the way, Maya is plagued with visions
of her ancestors.
She eventually embraces them and is rewarded
with superpowers.
"Echo" shows that Maya is stronger, both literally
and figuratively, when she accepts her family,
her past, and her flaws.
She tries to pass this on to Kingpin during
their final fight, forcing him to relive his
most painful memories.
When Maya encourages Fisk to let go of his
pain, Fisk instead runs away, appearing more
like a frightened child than an intimidating
crime lord.
"What did you do?"
The strength of families has been a part of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe throughout its
many phases, from the very first "Thor" movie
to 2021's "Eternals."
While tragedy and trauma might make many people
run away from the ones they love the most,
"Echo" shows that Maya is her best self when
she's fighting to protect them.
Fans eager to see Maya Lopez come into her
own as a superhero in "Echo" had to wait a
bit.
It takes all five episodes for the character
to embrace her heroic side.
It's not until her conversation with Chula
in episode 4 that Maya learns that her powers
come from her ancestors calling to her.
"Generations are echoing, reaching out to
us at a time when we need them the most."
Some critics felt the explanations for Maya's
superhero abilities were underdeveloped, with
The Ringer writing,
"Lopez's superpowers [...] manifest late in
the season but are never really explained
or demonstrated clearly."
There are many different powers showcased
among the Lopez women, from her mother's ability
to heal, to Maya's ability to force others
to experience visions, as she does with Kingpin.
Ultimately, it appears that Maya's superpowers
are gifts given to her by her ancestors.
While the exact details of what she can do
remain unclear, the important distinction
is that Maya is being aided along her journey
by the strong Choctaw women who came before
her.
The main lesson from Maya's story is that
she is stronger when she embraces that she's
living as a result of her family's past, not
in spite of it.
In the series, Maya's superpowers are rooted
in Choctaw mythology, with her oldest ancestor
Chafa becoming a heroic figure of the Choctaw
creation myth.
Many aspects of Choctaw mythology play an
integral role in shaping Maya's powers.
This comes as a huge shift for those familiar
with the character from Marvel Comics.
Maya first appeared in 1999, sent by Kingpin
to antagonize Daredevil.
The two adversaries eventually became romantically
entangled.
Maya's connections to Kingpin in the comics
are similar to those in the series.
However, one massive change comes with her
powers.
In the comics, Maya has photographic reflexes,
allowing her to copy her opponents' movements.
This is, coincidentally, a similar ability
to Taskmaster, who appeared as an antagonist
in 2021's "Black Widow."
It's not the first time Marvel has done this
with their characters, as they made similar
changes to Kamala Khan in the 2022 series
"Ms. Marvel."
Her abilities were also reinterpreted to fit
her cultural background and ancestral history.
"Echo" director and executive producer Sydney
Freeland explained the change as an attempt
to be more representative of Choctaw history.
Freeland told Variety in 2023,
"Her power in the comic books [is] kind of
lame.
[...] Representation was extremely important
to myself and to everyone on the crew."
"Echo" is one of Marvel's more ambitious projects,
despite also being its shortest at only five
episodes.
As the show's star Alaqua Cox told Collider,
the emotional scenes with Vincent D'Onofrio
towards the end were challenging.
As she put it,
"I remember looking on the call sheet for
the next day and seeing how it was such an
intense, emotional scene, and I said, 'Oh,
crap.'"
Naturally, though, she also hoped the show
left fans wanting more, stating,
"We never know where Maya is gonna go next,
so I think that they'll all be curious about
that."
The supporting actors in "Echo" also felt
somewhat intimidated by the project.
Also speaking to Collider, Devery Jacobs,
who plays Bonnie, singled out the finale's
Pow-Wow as a daunting set piece, saying,
"It was done so beautifully by our director,
Sydney Freeland, who is just, like, a rock
star in all of it, and I don't think that
we could have brought it home with anyone
else."
Vincent D'Onofrio also described to Entertainment
Weekly how the final scene of Kingpin sets
up a promising future for his character when
he said,
"There are so many places to go with this
character, it's crazy."
D'Onofrio also feels optimistic about his
return in "Daredevil: Born Again."
He continued,
"The reception of 'Echo' so far is helping
everybody understand that this is a really
good tone for 'Daredevil' too.
I think 'Born Again' is heading in that direction
in a major way now."
There are plenty of other firsts with "Echo,"
and one of them has to do with branding.
The show is designated as a "Marvel Spotlight,"
which is meant to signify that a certain show
or movie can be watched as a standalone project,
even if you're not familiar with the rest
of the MCU.
Because "Echo" is the first to be labeled
as such, its success will likely determine
Marvel's ambition in moving forward with future
"Marvel Spotlight" projects.
The show's success, unfortunately, may also
determine Maya Lopez's future in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe at large.
Unlike other Marvel series, "Echo" does not
end with confirmation that Maya Lopez will
return — and considering the character's
current irrelevance to the larger Multiverse
Saga of Phases 4 through 6, she might just
remain a supporting cast member in future
projects.
One of those may be "Daredevil: Born Again,"
in which Charlie Cox and Vincent D'Onofrio
will both be appearing.
There's certainly a lot of stories to be told
involving Maya Lopez, if her comic book history
is any indication.
At one point, the character dons the mantle
of Ronin, and at another time, she becomes
a host for the Phoenix Force.
Maya was also nearly included in the "Moon
Knight" series as a potential love interest
for Oscar Isaac's Marc Spector, so it's possible
that those two characters could cross paths
at some point.
Of course, it wouldn't be a Marvel Cinematic
Universe installment without a hint as to
what's coming up.
In a mid-credits scene for the final episode
of "Echo," Vincent D'Onofrio's Kingpin sits
on his private jet waiting to take off and
return to New York.
His attention is caught by a news program
on the plane TV, in which New York City's
mayoral election is being discussed.
"A bare-knuckle brawler would do well in this
race, an outsider, someone who is not afraid
to take on the establishment."
The look on Fisk's face seems to indicate
that he intends to join the campaign — and
knowing how powerful he is in New York City,
he'll likely win.
This could set the stage for Fisk's role in
"Daredevil: Born Again."
Despite reports of creative overhauls in recent
months, D'Onofrio confirmed on Twitter the
changes are all positive, telling Variety,
"Frankly I'd be worried if we were settling
for less."
This would make "Daredevil: Born Again" an
adaptation of an integral Kingpin storyline
from Marvel Comics, in which Wilson Fisk becomes
the mayor of New York City and furthers his
plans to resurrect his dead wife, Vanessa.
Fisk's new position could also find him at
odds with other NYC-based superheroes, such
as Spider-Man, Doctor Strange, and Kate Bishop
— yet again.
"Echo" is certainly one of the more exciting
projects in the Marvel Cinematic Universe's
recent output.
Whether it's because of the focus on a deaf,
disabled, Indigenous character or its depiction
of violence more akin to the beloved Netflix
shows, it certainly feels like a step forward.
The biggest step, though, is the involvement
of the Choctaw nation during the show's development.
As director Sydney Freeland described to Deadline,
"The Choctaws were so crucial ... because
they had their own written histories or oral
histories and cultures and traditions that
were drawn from, and it really was a collaboration
between myself, our production and the Choctaws."
That didn't go unappreciated by Marvel.
Right before the credits roll on "Echo," a
title card specifically thanks the Choctaw
Nation of Oklahoma for their consultations
on the project.
The collaboration didn't stop at the development
stage, either.
Marvel has included a Choctaw language dub
of "Echo" on streaming services, and members
of the Choctaw Nation went into detail regarding
their work with Marvel on the Nation's official
website.
It's quite possible that we could see more
Native American Marvel characters appear on-screen
soon, like Wyatt Wingfoot or Warpath.